elle la queue dans les transports les
italiens reprennent depuis ce lundi
leurs vieilles habitudes bus métro ou
non le port du masque est exigée mais
une impression domine le soulagement à
ouchy ray c'était un sentiment positif
d'aller au travail ce matin après deux
mois à la maison c'était agréable
il ya toujours un peu de peur mais j'ai
été rassuré par ce que j'ai vu dans le
métro tout le monde portait des masques
à gaz et commençons la phase 2 de
manière positive
nous devrons être forts et capables de
nous adapter à cette situation pour
revenir le plus rapidement possible à
une vie normale
[Musique]
4,4 millions de personnes sont attendues
sur les chantiers dans les bureaux les
usines ou encore les boutiques stefano
par exemple a rouvert sa papeterie
non sans quelques inquiétudes ce périple
aux médias amour et je dois tout
désinfecter
j'ai déjà des masques les clients
doivent entrer dans le magasin en
portant un masque et respecter une
distance de sécurité
si j'y arrive j'achèterai du gel
désinfectant pour les mains
le gouvernement nous a donné 600 euros
d'argent de poche
il aurait pu faire plus c'est sûr mais
c'est mieux que rien avant une
réouverture complète le 1er juin les
bars et les restaurants proposent dès
aujourd'hui des plans emporté un bol
d'air frais pour des italiens autoriser
de nouveau à se promener et à faire de
l'exercice à l'extérieur